To Kazakhstan now, which is still reeling
after a week of deadly unrest that left more
than 200 people dead. The unrest exposed a
leadership struggle. To tighten his grip,
President Kassym-Jomart Tokayev
has now taken over the leadership
of the ruling party - sidelining his
mentor and the former head of state.
Protests started over a rise in fuel
prices at the beginning of the year,
but then spiraled into mass disturbances -
notably in Kazakhstan's biggest city, Almaty.
Security forces are accused of using
excessive force to put down the unrest.
Many in Almaty still can't believe what
happened. DW's Emily Sherwin has more.
A city turned into a warzone. This is
Kazakhstan's commercial center, Almaty,
in early January. What started as anger
over rising fuel prices soon escalated
into full blown riots, arson and looting.
Many locals tell us they are still in shock.
"What were they even trying
to take here? Ice cream?"
Botagoz Seidakhmetova's apartment is right on the
corner of Almaty's Republic Square, the location
of the city administration building – and the
epicenter of the recent unrest. Out of her window,
she witnessed peaceful protests turning violent.
"I guess I went a bit nuts. I opened my window
and started shouting at the rioters:
You should be ashamed of yourselves,
what are you doing? The people who opened
these shops are people just like you!"
Rebuilding will take time.
The authorities estimate the value of the
damage to local businesses in the country
at over 150 million euros. Nearly 2,000
shops suffered at the hands of the rioters.
Artist and designer Mimi Ilnitskaya
has been picking up the pieces.
She is convinced that her workshop
and office in Almaty's city center
was set on fire. During the protests,
Ilnitskaya was at home with her children.
The destruction she found when she
returned to her workplace shocked her.
"When I was coming up here, I was worried
that I hadn't taken the key to my office.
But then I came in and realized I don't
need a key, there's not even a desk.
I never thought my own
people could do this to me."
Authorities say over two hundred
people died during the riots.
The government insists foreign terrorists
and extremists are to blame for the unrest.
But some experts believe the ruling elite used the
protests as part of an internal power struggle.
Almaty resident Botagoz Seidakhmetova
tells us she can't forget what happened.
"I'm still scared, even now. It's a deep,
animal fear - because I suddenly felt that
we are living in anarchy - rather than
in a state. We don't have a government
that can protect me and other normal people."
The Kazakh authorities say that the situation
across the country is back under control. But
trust in the government may also need rebuilding.